thank you
this is more than just a ball it's the
official world cup ball more colorful
than previous editions
and it has a special name
no other object has had quite the same
impact on the stars at the tournament as
this fall
it was developed by german added as
product manager jochlen raff
three different elements inspired the
design
the most obvious are these bands around
the ball
they've got this typically brazilian
flowing shape
and they're also reminiscent of the wish
bracelets that are popular throughout
brazil
and of course you have the colors and
the star theme that plays a big role in
brazil
this is where the idea came about
the headquarters of sportswear giant
adidas near nuremberg
jochen raff's team worked more than two
and a half years on the new ball before
it went into production
alongside the new look the construction
is different too the ball surface is
made of six identical panels that are
sewn together
the more uniformly the seams are
distributed the better the ball flies to
the air
the long seams and the uniform
construction are what count
then it doesn't matter how the ball is
oriented it still has a predictable
flight path
the design underwent extensive testing
in the lab before it went to the world
cup
a special machine checked if the ball
was perfectly round and symmetrical a
mechanical kickbot was used to test the
ball's flight characteristics and
professional soccer players tried it out
too
the grocery fund was really selling the
field tests were the most time consuming
part
we consulted teams in the bundesliga and
the us
two years ago we tested the ball in
brazil
and those things took time
but once we checked off all those steps
we knew we had the best ball we could
come up with
we ask um from a local berlin soccer
team to test the ball for euromax
they practice several times a week on
this pitch in the centre of town
the design is funky and fresh and it's
colorful definitely fun to play with
it's kind of based on a golf ball
because you see this raised part here
it has more stability when you kick it
we use a similar ball every weekend it's
the bundesliga ball which isn't all that
different from this one
the surface is great a different feeling
than our training ball
forget about this old bundesliga ball
i'll take this one the bazooka is the
culmination of a long evolution this
2000 year old chinese football was
stuffed with feathers and hair
until the 1960s world cup balls were
made of strips of brown leather
adidas made the first official world cup
ball in 1970 since then each design has
been given a special name
that was the first time we had a white
ball with these black pentagons to make
it easier to see
today everyone knows the design
but that world cup was the first time we
saw it
as the years and tournaments went on the
design was refined
from leather to synthetics from black
and white to multi-colored
the adidas team also came up with a
special ball for the final match
at that point the enthusiasm has reached
an absolute peak that's why we see these
bands of color bursting out of the panel
and all the little details we wanted it
to express all that emotion like a dance
a samba or music
it all comes pouring out
the designers were inspired by shapes
used by brazilian star architect oscar
niemeyer and by their experiences during
a trip to brazil
the ball is the iconic piece of
equipment in a tournament like this
we want to imbue it with the history of
the host country as a kind of tribute
that way we can see that this was the
ball they used in brazil
whether you call it an icon a high-tech
product or just a soccer ball during the
2014 world cup at least all eyes will be
on the bazooka